Now, that we can receive the position of our physics object in the world, we
have to figure out how to set the position of a physics body, which in contrast
is a little bit trickier. Scrolling through the documentation, you'll most
likely see a nice API called set position, which will do exactly what you
think, and set the position physics body in the world, regardless of how
physics are acting upon it. Note that this type of teleportation will ignore
any types of collision that may occur before the position is set. In other
words, set position teleports you to the desired position first, and then
calculates the physics response. As such, you should only use set position when
you're intentionally trying to teleport, and, when you know where you're going.
Imagine how Nightcrawler feels. So, in order to get moving with this, the first
thing we need to do, is once the physBody has been created, we can actually
call the SetLinearVelocity function, on the physBody. Setting its initial
velocity vector, so this body can be simulated and updated properly. And if you
recall, we remove the velocity from objects each frame, in order to keep them
from sliding around our world like hockey pucks. As such, any objects that want
continuous movement, say for instance a rocket moving at a constant speed, need
to set the linear velocity of the physBody, each frame, to insure it's moving.
We see a perfect example of this in the simple projectile class, which will set
the linear velocity, before sampling from the physBody.